good morning about the episode genzyme
the group's anniversary is a very
important day for the euro countries with
an intense agenda during the day it is for
humans splits that are crucial
property of the euro is we have the
important meeting about greece is
we have very positive information is  of
greece on the fulfillment of the
commitments that grows to assume in this
fourth revision of the program and greece
fulfilled all the 88 measures that were
read in this in this in this revision that is
exactly the remarkable commitment of
the greek authorities in the program
I am confident that we will take decisions
on the package  debt on
greek debt that will make it sustainable and
allow greece to access
markets sustainably and its own
parents
this is a very important moment for
the greek economy and i am confident that
today marks a new phase for the
greek economy in the same way  for the euro area
today will also make a difference as
to what the future of the euro is we have  a
difficult agenda that has been worked on
for many many months
is the idea is to force the banks of the
banking system and create new lines of defense
for europe for a future that is
full of uncertainties but is that it is
built on very
economic fundamentals as that  those of us
who live today are not in the euro area and
we also have pedestrians on the council of
governors of the water body also it
is european it is a day without activities and
we will talk later about vasco go to
these meetings
thank you very much